كومبايره ترك الى ابي مجموعه صغيره من
اللوحات ومع تقدم في العمر قررت جلبها الى
ليتوانيا وانا بدوري انجز فيديوهات وصور
فوتوغرافيه لذا اقابل اناسا كثيرين من
بينهم توماس سبيراتس وزير الخارجيه ولكونه
هو من يعين السفراء فقد كرمني بتعيين
سفيرا بل اقدم مؤخرا على تعييني وكيلا
للوزاره يتيح لهذا المنصب لقاء الكثيرين
وتقديم مزايا اذوبيس اليهم في هذه
الجمهوريه تجر الامور بالعمل الطوعي يتم
تنظيم معارض فنيه
جي بوليسيه
من مدينه كونس لزياره العاصمه فلينيس
فوجدت هذا الحي الفني مثيرا للاهتمام
جمهوريه اوزوبيست تزخر بالالوان وفنون
الشوارع ففكرت انها مدينه سيحلوا لي العيش
فيها ووجدتني بشكل عفوي استاجروا مسكنا
هنا مع اقرانه عندما كنت طالبه ثم انتقلت
الى مدينه اخرى
وبعدها عدت الى فلين ياس واستاجرت هذا
الاستديو لفن الرقص المعاصر قدمت عروضا في
مسرح الشارع في اوزوبيس وقمت بانجاز بعض
ابتكاراتي فلا حظت انني امضي وقتا طويلا
هنا صحيح ادركت انني ساظل هنا اياما
وليالي نعم هنا يتجلى الابداع